Many of the
people
they blindly follow actresses, actor and
celebrities
blindly. You know people who see a lot
of Hindi movies from
Bollywood. They want to settle in
Bombay. Why? Because Amitab Bachan comes
to Bombay and within few weeks, few
months he becomes a multi-millionaire.
So they think if we settle in Bombay
because of Bollywood we will become
[Music]
multi-millionaire then someone buys a
car
Hyundai Sentro I 10 why we bought this
car because Shah Ruk Khan he was adding
this
car I doubt whether Shah Ruk Khan ever
sat in a Honda Centro i 10 before after
that for the ad for the money he might
have sat he may be having maybe a BMW or
a Mercedes I didn't do
research but he may not be driving a
Sentro highend i10 maybe for the ad he
got money so for the ad he might have
sat in that car after that I doubt he
ever sat in a Hyundai Sanro
i10 you know many of the actors and
celebrities they are brand
ambassadors like the brand ambassador of
Tagore
Tagore watch is Shah Rukh Khan. So you
think if you wear a tag or watch you'll
become Shah Ruk
Khan. So this is called blindly
following. Blind
following.
Then there are
people who have a goal like one
businessman he buys a
textile
factory because he knows that in textile
industry good profit so he buys it and
he has openly ceremony so when we ask
him that have you appointed a CEO he
says no then we ask him where are you
going to buy the textile from he says I
don't
know where you going to sell your
textile he says I don't know so he has a
goal that means he knows that in textile
industry there's profit but no planning
goal without
planning let me give you another
example there's a person who wants to
become the greatest scientist he wants
to become a good scientist so he does
research and he finds out that the
greatest scientist of humankind was
Isaac
Newton. So he does his research and then
he starts growing hair like Isaac
Newton. He wears clothes like Isaac
Newton. He wears shoes like Isaac
Newton. Do you think he'll become a
scientist? He has a
goal. He also has a planning but wrong
planning. He thinks by keeping hair like
Isaac Newton or wearing clothes like
Isaac Newton or wearing shoes like Isaac
Newton he will become a scientist. So
this is an example of a
goal with planning but wrong
planning. Who is the
best who can give the reply to the
question what is the purpose of our
lives? Is it a
teacher? Can the best answer be given by
a doctor, by a
psychologist? Can it be given by Dr.
Zakai? No. The best reply can be given
by our creator Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala. And Allah gives this reply in
surah chapter number 51 verse number 56.
And I started my talk with this verse of
the
Quran that we have created the jin and
the men not but to worship me. So Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala our creator our
sustainer our
cherisher he is telling us in the last
and final revelation the glorious
Quran that we have created the jin and
the men not but to worship him worship
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala so our main
purpose of life is to worship Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala the Arabic word used
here is ibada coming from the root root
word Arabic abd meaning a servant a
slave. So ibada
means following the commandments of
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala. Whenever you
follow the commandments of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala, it is called as
ibada. It is called as worshiping Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala.